I was wondering when I would come in
here to find you sitting in that chair
was it easy tracking you down Decker
wasn't supposed to be I know you have
retired but that's all behind me now
general not the man you knew during the
Cold War I understand we're now facing a
threat unlike any we've ever faced
before a man with your expertise
I made a foul
never to kill another human being sorry
general I have to find someone else
oh no we uh we weren't thinking you'd do
it we were just hoping you could
recommend someone for the job I guess I
could come out of retirement
no no need just a recommendation will do
all right I'll do it
you know you're just not what we're
looking for you sly son of a [ __ ] you
always knew how to push my buttons men
not you Decker sharpest I ever was even
faster too grab my hand oh wait till I
count to three first one two three would
you try and slap me in the face I wasn't
ready for that
try again okay you know what yeah what
didn't have my adrenaline up cuz this is
not an actual high-stakes situation draw
your weapon are disarmed
[Music]
you're getting pretty quick and disarmed
okay I don't need to take your weapon
[Music]
you know what
shoot me I am NOT going to shoot you in
the shoulder
this is ridiculous see what happens
okay I made a mistake coming here I'd
rather not you you caught the bullet so
you're telling me that the bullet is in
between your hands right now let's go
already
I was oh wait one second
you